check this out an illegal immigrant with
a gun makes it across the border it's
horrifying it's in the Eagle Pass area
where I spent a lot of time it comes as
CBP reports nearly
250,000 migrants encountered at the
border making it the highest November on
record the third highest month on uh in
history penal County Arizona sheriff and
US Senate candidate Mark Lamb joins us
now Sheriff thank you Merry Christmas
ahead of time for Border Patrol agents
in law enforcement uh like yourself
won't necessarily be with their loved
ones because of the unprecedented surge
at the border from Texas to Arizona
Thousand Miles separates Eagle Pass and
lukeville and yet the agents are
overwhelmed in both locations what if
you were to be elected to the Senate
what is the first thing you do to secure
this
border well Merry Christmas to you too
Griff Griff and thanks for having me on
today look we got to get back the
easiest is go back to the Trump era
policies we've got to shut the border
down secure the border and we've got to
restore the remaining Mexico program the
majority of these people are on false
Asylum claims they don't have true
Asylum claims they're getting court
dates from five to seven years from now
and when they go to court the judges are
going to have to determine that they
don't have a legitimate Asylum claim and
then we're going to have a mass
deportation situation on our hands and
so we've got to get back to securing the
Border first and foremost which would
stop the fenel it would weaken the
cartels and it would allow border patrol
to get back to doing their job because
right now they're completely handcuffed
and Sheriff I just want to show this
photo one more time of the migrant with
the gun and why this is significant
because we see the thousands upon
thousands 10 12,000 a day of the give
UPS this is a known gotway this image
was taken of a border patrol unit that
is back at headquarters and you go P
looking at the cam camera when they see
migrants that are coming across that
they can't send any agents to respond to
to apprehend them they mark them down to
not them that's why we know there are
79,000 known guideways border wide since
the new fiscal year began on October 1
in this case I confirmed with uh border
patrol sources there that they saw this
individual these individuals coming
across and that one individual with the
gun they could not send agents to
respond so this individual got into the
US and was free to roam with a rifle how
serious of a national security threat
are we facing with the condition of the
border now oh look this is the greatest
threat to National Security that
Americans are facing on the southern
border this is an Eagle pass in the
Tucson sector where I'm at this is not
an uncommon occurrence there are plenty
of people that come across with guns and
these are all the the majority of the
Goda ways are happening in the Tucson
sector which is where we're at now my
guys were out flying with border patrol
the other day we were responding to a
couple rescue missions where people
where the cartels will leave people for
be uh behind for dead we try to go
rescue them and while we were doing that
my guys were saying Sheriff we've never
seen it like this there's people
everywhere out there in the desert and a
lot of those Goda ways the PE the
coyotes leaving them leading them in are
are armed and it should be concerning to
every American because we have no idea
who's coming in they all Americans
should be concerned Le and I don't mean
to be a downer two days before Christmas
but Sheriff I began my border coverage
career more than 12 years ago in Penal
County I understand you guys are as
seasoned as anyone coming from you that
is a concern Sheriff Mark Lam have a
Merry Christmas thanks for taking time
thanks Griff Merry Christmas to you too
God bless God bless I'm Steve duy I'm
Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis